Well, we know that he is
a great comforter,
the president... (CHUCKLES)
...because we saw him
with a group of victims
of gun violence this week,
we saw in Puerto Rico before,
when he talked to
the war widow on the phone,
comforting is not his thing.
He had to have a crib sheet.
Look at that, it's in his hand.
They actually wrote--
Look at the last one:
"I hear you."
(SCATTERED LAUGHTER)
They had to write
on the bottom of it,
"I hear you,"
for him to be reminded
to say that.
We found out that
in the Trump administration,
everybody has these crib sheets,
you know, like notes to self.
(SCATTERED LAUGHTER)
So it's a new department here,
it's called "Notes to Self."
(ERIC LAUGHS)
-We're gonna show you
what everybody in the...
-(APPLAUSE)
...Trump White House, er...
For example, Donald Trump Jr.:
"Food goes in mouth."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Jeff Sessions:
"It's 'African-American,'
not 'colored'."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
These are things
they have to remind themselves.
Sarah Huckabee Sanders has
"Wife beaters = bad."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-"Oh, I see."
(ERIC LAUGHS)
Rick Perry,
our energy secretary:
"Don't call it ''lectricity'"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Melania: "It's so big,
you're hurting me."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Yes...
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Oh!
Ivanka's says, "Refer to Jared
as 'husband'
not 'co-conspirator'."
(APPLAUSE)
Jared: "Find out what
'two-state solution' means."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Sean Hannity:
"Don't get any in your hair."
AUDIENCE: Oh!
(CHUCKLES)
Ted Cruz: "Watch what humans do,
act like them."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
(APPLAUSE)
And John Kelly:
"Unplug nuclear button." Please!